the russian stock market saw its value
halved as investors calculated the toll
of tightening sanctions on russian
companies biggest one-day tumble for the
ruble forcing russia's central bank to
step in stock markets from asia to north
america were in the red as investors
were spooked by fears about what could
happen next and how that could take a
bite out of corporate profits
oil prices were the standouts spiking
past 100 dollars a barrel for the first
time in eight years with this type of
moving oil prices gasoline prices are
going to move higher as well and there
is going to be
some some shock at the pump and that's
just the start we have to think about
transportation and how few costs are
going to be impacting transportation we
do have a trucking economy in north
america higher energy costs mean higher
transportation costs so expect inflation
to surge as almost everything is trucked
or shipped in at least one bay street
economist expects inflation to be around
six percent in march that will influence
the bank of canada's upcoming decision
on interest rates you can't rule
anything out but at this point if it's
status quo for the next seven days or so
a 25 basis point rate hike is is almost
certainly in the cards ukraine is
europe's breadbasket a major producer of
corn and wheat which sent prices of both
commodities higher and there'll be
fallout for canadian farmers as well
facing long wait times for equipment and
higher costs of production because key
chemicals come from ukraine as a result
of this conflict bringing more
uncertainty
were
we're going to see probably fertilizer
prices go up as well further
exacerbating supply chain snarls means
higher prices for consumer goods but
market analysts say it's not the time to
sell in a panic or make major changes to
your investment strategy ann gaviola
global news toronto